hi I'm Erik Bosse since Star Wars the
last Jedi left us with some big
questions for where the franchise could
go in Episode nine and because it's
never too soon to speculate on the
future of Star Wars with only the
slightest shreds of real information
let's break down some predictions for
episode 9 based on promises the first
two films of the new trilogy seemed to
leave us with an historical precedent of
how Lucasfilm Disney in this creative
team tends to deliver on those kinds of
promises and in case any of these shots
in the dark end up being right spoiler
warning I guess also I guess spoiler
warning for the last Jedi in case you're
I guess waiting to binge all the movies
until the last one comes out okay first
off let's talk about Leia in Episode
nine the original game plan for this new
trilogy was for Episode seven to be Han
Solo's story from snowed eight to be
Luke Skywalker story in Episode nine to
be Leia's story but after Carrie
Fisher's death in December 2016
Lucasfilm president Kathleen Kennedy
confirmed that they were pretty much
starting over with whatever story ideas
they had Fisher's daughter Billie lourd
who plays lieutenant conics in the
movies allow them to use her mother's
likeness in Episode nine if they wanted
but the studio confirmed they would not
be going in that direction so here is my
first prediction for episode nine I
think the story will pick up after a
long time jump during which we'll learn
through exposition dialogue that general
Organa passed away do I think the
opening crawl will lead with general
Leia Organa is dead no god no well
hopefully not that would be kind of
tone-deaf
instead I expect the opening scenes will
take place years later showing us a new
commander of the resistance Poe Dameron
perhaps now at the rank of Admiral or
general who would mention something
about Leah's passing Disney has actually
had to do something like this before
for Pixar's Cars to Paul Newman who did
the voice of DOC in the first film had
passed away between the movies and the
characters lightly reference Doc's
departure the third cars actually did a
pretty good job turning Doc's memory
into a key emotional motivator for the
story and I could see Disney wanting to
do a similar thing with Leah's legacy
but more on that later I also think a
time jump is necessary for the story at
the end of the last Jedi the resistance
forces had been worn down too by my
count in those final scenes around 20
fighters they're literally all aboard
the
falken yeah it's not much of an army if
it can fit on one party bus but at the
end of the movie when Leia told ray we
have everything we need followed by a
scene of stable kids on canto by telling
the story of Luke's last stand and
wishing upon a star with old rebel swag
the implication was that the resistance
lives on to a new generation a slow burn
that will take at least a few years to
rebuild into a fire large enough to take
on the first order moving on to another
big question people have about episode 9
will director JJ Abrams return to some
of those loose threads he left in the
force awakens the importance of Ray's
parents no kiss villain the Knights of
Ren since Rian Johnson kind of did away
with him in the last Jedi I'll get to
that but first a quick update on Abrams
he took over directing duties for
episode 9 and teamed up with writer
Chris Terrio to finish the trilogy
he recently pitched the final story idea
to Disney head Bob Iger and episode 9 is
now using the working title of Black
Diamond and don't get too excited Black
Diamond probably doesn't mean anything
in relation to the universe for example
the last Jedi's working title was space
bear which was an inside joke from Rian
Johnson about their struggle to figure
out how the story would go and the joke
that a space bear could fly in and save
the day
episode 9 s current release date is
scheduled for December 20th 2019 which
is still about two years away so really
the whole story this movie is still very
much up in the air but from what we know
about JJ Abrams as a filmmaker I
wouldn't get your hopes up for any clear
answers so my second prediction JJ
Abrams will keep the mysteries a mystery
Abrams whole philosophy as a creator is
a concept he refers to as the mystery
box basically the idea that the mystery
itself has far more storytelling value
than the answer inside the box and sure
this can be maddening for fans but if
you think of it as a strategy to hook
you into the story and then win you over
with super likable characters and
well-directed action it's really super
successful so looking at Abrams this way
the mysteries he's set up in the force
awakens and Rey's whole force vision
flashback we're puzzle pieces he
probably never intended to put together
Tim Buzzle pieces are more valuable
unassembled and hung on a wall as their
own works of art so yeah maybe we'll see
the Knights of Ren but I doubt we'll
learn their first names or anything
really I think this lack of full
resolution will also apply to the war
between the resistance in the first
order so let's move on to our neck
prediction the resistance will probably
win the battle but probably not the war
not yet maybe not ever in the last Jedi
Rian Johnson didn't do a ton to set up
for a sequel but one story line did
leave us with a bit of mystery Benicio
Del Toro's character DJ who betrays Finn
and rose of the first order for a hefty
payoff
DJ cynically tells Finn they blow you up
today you blow them up tomorrow it's
just business then respond saying you're
wrong and then DJ after considering this
says maybe this response not only leaves
the door open for DJ to return in
episode 9 which he probably will most
likely is a han Solo tight money driven
chaotic neutral who eventually joins a
cause it suggests the outcomes of these
constant galactic Wars are never clean
and he's right the conflicts are never
over because the ending stuff is boring
the destruction of both Death Star's
eventually of course led to a resurgence
of the dark forces even if the
resistance overcomes the first order
it'll probably be by the skin of its
teeth really so that doesn't even keep
making more and more star wars but one
thing that I do think is clearly over
and I don't think JJ Abrams can or
really should change this is the Jedi
Order and honestly the Skywalker saga
wow the relationship between Rey and
kylo Ren who by the way is now supreme
leader of the first order seems to
remain the driving force of the story
the last Jedi made it clear that this
conflict was no longer just about Jedi
versus Sith or pure light versus pure
dark the big message of the movie is
that the force is more about the balance
between these two sides so when Luke and
force Ghost Yoda watched the last
remnant of the Jedi Order burn I think
it's a pretty clear signal that the Jedi
as we know it are not meant to last but
really the deeper takeaway of all this
was spoken directly by kylo in the film
for the first time on a metal level the
last Jedi signaled a turning point away
from the Skywalker family drama that had
dominated the saga kylo severed his
remaining ties to his bloodline and
Rey's bloodline was revealed to be
completely unexceptional so my next
prediction is the Jedi tradition will
transform into something new as I
pointed out my breakdown the last Jedi
which you should definitely go check out
if you haven't already one of the
closing shots in the movies shows that
Rey actually took the ancient Jedi texts
from the tree library I believe she will
read those and interpret them in a new
way
maybe realize some alternate translation
that changes the meaning of the Jedi
Code and become a new sort of Jedi
Master maybe something that doesn't even
use the term Jetta that might involve
rebuilding Luke and Anakin's old
lightsaber that got severed in the last
Jedi
some have suggested that given Rey's
skills of the bo staff would be cool for
that new lightsaber to be dual bladed
we'll see also another shot earlier in
the film showed that Kyber crystal
necklace in Luke's home maybe that's the
one that Shirley use to power this new
saber I think whatever this new order is
it could be something that kylo Ren
could get on board with like Rey he's
also now removed from the Skywalker's as
well as the Jedi SIF conflict so I don't
think kylo will be the purely evil
villain in episode 9 general Hux now
seems to have space nazi covered so Rey
unlocking this new avenue of the force
could be a way to turn kylos heart
really I think episode 9 will measure
these characters by their ability to
truly finally let the past die and I
think one form that conflict could take
leads me to my final prediction Luke
will return as a force ghost to help Rey
but also maybe to haunt kylo in Luke's
final confrontation with kylo he made
two bold promises one strike me down in
anger and I'll always be with you
and then after revealing that he was
just a projection see a round kid to me
these are pretty much guarantees that
Luke will haunt kylo as a force ghost
Jacob Marley or a Banquo to slowly drive
this [ __ ] insane until he either
destroys himself or changes his ways
Luke's wording also implies that others
whom kylo struck down in anger might
similarly haunt him for example how
great would it be to see Harrison Ford
cameo is another force ghost bickering
with Luke as they trail kylo everywhere
it goes I'm just saying the long hair
looks kind of weird
what's wrong with long hair and even
though the studio promised footage of
Carrie Fisher wouldn't at all appear in
episode 9 who knows maybe we'll hear an
echo of her voice to imply some other
lasting presence that these characters
will struggle to move on from I just
really want to hear Carrie Fisher's say
get your head out of your cockpit one
last time but as we wait for more
details about episode 9 to come out my
question for you guys is which of the
two previous installments do you think
episode 9 will be more similar to JJ
Abrams nostalgic adventure the force
awakens or the darker game changer the
last Jedi I would say
force awakens but Abram says said that
he'd loved the last Jedi and wishes he
had written script so maybe he'll try to
move more in that direction no matter
what this third chapter has to be darker
than verse one was comment with your
take down below or tweet me directly I
da boss and follow new rock stars on
Twitter at new rock stars for updates on
our videos like this video and subscribe
to new rock stars for more Star Wars
coverage including more deep dives in
the last Jedi again make sure to check
out my breakdown as well as all the
details about the upcoming solo a Star
Wars story and if you really like us you
can contribute to us on patreon big
thanks to all of our donors especially
ponies start thanks for watching bye